[Music]
and WTS News Wednesday Thursday Friday
submitted by Hendrick a white
supremacist converts to Islam and then
killed his neo-nazi roommates for
disrespecting his new faith huh this was
crazy
interesting it's ironic this is like all
types of bucks left in the story by
Roenick Jackson why is he so crazy I'm
not sure why he's amazing
but I do know that he was saying things
like you know your country needs to stop
bombing my country oh wow yeah an
identity crisis
definitely yeah so this is kid he's from
Florida I want to fill in the blanks I
think I know what happened happened so
in the while he was researching his
enemy hmm you know and you know like
learning about terrorism and all this
stuff and I says he actually started to
like them because you know after a while
he realized they're actually more alike
than not alike that's what happened and
then he said you know what this guy's
interesting let me learn more about it
and let me see if this is more for me
that's what happened maybe you pretty
much realized amirite honest neo-nazi
homies oh this is a great Pocahontas
story yeah so this kid is 18 years old
his name is Devin what this is what he
looks like
this is what it looks like he's so angry
very why are you so angry buddy - we
keep killing his D from you can boy no
Laura oh I know he look very European
look easy in the jail time mm-hmm and he
is kiss he doesn't look that take I mean
he doesn't look that neo-nazi to me what
Tennille it like when they're in fall
like super army fatigue their bald
tatted up and then to have a swastika on
their forehead we're gonna American
history axe the hardcore ones
maybe this is what they
like in the beginning and by the time
they're 40 they look like that maybe
yeah so what this guy did is I don't
know exactly how it went down I just
know that what he ended up doing is he's
shot his two roommates
Wow years old 18 year olds shot him in
the head and in the body so they're dead
they're dead they're gone they're
neo-nazi roommates so that's what he's
claiming but the sister of one of the
victim said that know my brother were in
her fly like I know that Devon when this
other guy his other roommates that
wasn't killed today was Brandon she's
like I know that they are neo-nazis but
not my brother and the other guy that
got killed that's what the sister saying
so we don't know but when police arrived
they found Brandon in front of the
apartment like crying and like holding
his you know his hands and his face in
his hands and he was just sobbing and so
when the cops went and they found that
in their garage there was bombs
materials a lot of different chemicals
that you know can create a bomb and
they're also found in a brick and hummus
what did a brother hummus not okay by
the family that was an important book
but they also found a framed photo of
the Oklahoma City bomber on his dresser
at kutsuki I know his name is Timothy
McVeigh Oh oh yeah teca's is Keith the
Unabomber yeah so like this dude this
kid Brandon he's just like obsessed with
like vitals that is Michael Jordan yes
okay and so he it seemed like he was
preparing for his own type of crazy-ass
attack because he had all these
chemicals in that house yes because you
just had a Sutekh and just made me
giggle
crazy ass attack I just heard a septic
yeah so in Brendan's 21 by the way so
really you have 16 no no though we'll
guys all the one that lives got it yeah
brother guy I don't have a picture of
Brandon Brandon yeah and so um yeah
they're just reporting like uh after he
after Devon shot his two roommates he
went over to a smoke shop and pulled out
a gun out of his waistband and said do
me a favor and get the saw
down and so human favor that's like the
most polite robbery do me a favor
everyone get down on the ground have his
voice crack at one point sit down
pardon me everyone attention please
I would like to make an announcement
brings out a cop I'm not interrupting
anyone ladies and gentlemen and you said
that and believe me a favor get the [ __ ]
on the ground have you told him to do me
a favor get the [ __ ] on the ground yeah
Oh Slim Shady please stand up I'm sure
when I presented oh yeah yeah so then
you said that to a female employee and a
male customer and apparently he asked
the customer why shouldn't I kill you
and there was a few minutes later
another customer went into the store and
he ordered him to get down he told all
three people in the store that he
already killed someone and then it just
got to a point where police arrived one
of the hostages got awakes the police
convinced Devin to let the other
husband's go and then that's when they
arrested him and he was making
references to Allah Allah Mohammed and
saying like I had to do it if I wouldn't
have happened if your country didn't
bomb my country while he's cookie just
country or Florida yeah he was born in
Florida whoa what if these terrorists
are so next level now they're just
infiltrating the minds of American youth
and making them think that they're
actually Isis kids Oh
nothin is happening a lot of
brainwashing a lot of play in the UK
their debts are actually from the Middle
East risen I don't know if they're
making anything that it's in the Middle
East but I know that they're convincing
a lot of teams I heard this happening a
lot in the UK that a lot of teams in the
UK were they were running away from home
and heading over to join Isis so
[ __ ] are they white kids white kids yeah
you've been females I think we even
talked about taking news because I knew
that there are a lot of kids leaving
like Western nations and going to the
Middle East to become a part of the
Islamic states but they were all non
white kids that didn't feel like they
fit in in these countries yeah I know
these are white kids they've been
they've been buying like a new Facebook
and Instagram has and so the demographic
they're targeting the white kids yeah
you can do that because you could target
now when you buy those apps they're
doing that and then I think in the UK is
the Sun sucks but it's hella sunny in
the Middle East so they're like would
you like to go to the beach without the
ocean being my girl you know she [ __ ]
like false advertising make these kids
like a postcard yeah it's like hey what
I want to win a free tropical adventure
and the kids like yeah I've been stuck
in this [ __ ] dim as place like let me
check it out and then it's like a music
video like do it and they're like church
but I like that festival video yeah it's
like a festival there's music wow and
then at the end of the video there's
like guys in masks with comes like look
oh my god they're gonna bubble hi you're
causing the gun come to Iraq where we
have sandy beaches and guns I mean you
guys extremely the new army ads right or
any kind of army on your last like ten
years yeah it pretty much looks like a
video game so it's really cool it looks
really cool like it's like watching like
an action movie or something so I feel
like a lot of kids who grow up playing
video games you know they look at that
and they're like oh [ __ ] you know I can
go and do my video game life for real
and so I feel like maybe the Instagram
advertising isn't too far off you know
what I hate to admit this but you guys
know I watch Isis training videos yeah
or research yeah and I've seen the way
that they recruit and I've seen the way
they do stuff and sometimes I see myself
going would you be like to be a part of
this group I could finally have my own
country stop saying that I don't want to
but I'm just telling you to choose not
why sometimes you don't have to say the
jig it's a lie I don't want to but then
I can see how it's they staged its
package it's so [ __ ] cool yeah so all
these kids they watch these videos and
you like has it gone to you because I
thought you keep pushing the second time
got a fever [ __ ] why are you telling
people to go see you you want them to
get recruited yeah what is your deal you
want to recruit for your country not
someone else or I would do but then I'm
just okay
I'm just letting you know we got to
understand the enemy before we do get a
job Brandon
why you need to I know it's a touch like
a door what was high I don't know what
your own training video and your own urk
I do yeah but you know what I love you
like Toyota sponsoring Isis because they
always have these luck in 1999 Toyota
pickup trucks that are brand [ __ ] new
and I'm like how worthy go to get these
trucks
I'm sure so it is not a sponsoring 1999
how do you don't jump on my back he's
the world's remoting I do you know you
need a uncoiled of [ __ ] eyebrow how
do you know go you need to go over there
he needs to just not speak about liking
I serious why every single one of those
cars or Toyota's from the 90s they match
like what where did they go that's how
you know you're not being brainwashed
she's paying attention to the wrong [ __ ]
good job Joe yay we still have a mother
if they were okay if they were Isis all
right all I'm saying is if they weren't
Isis they seem like a cool bunch of guys
that I might want to talk reading the
ISIS you take your Jamaa in video that's
what I'm saying because I know who they
are I'm like [ __ ] you guys that's like
me being a blood and watching a quick
video and going like that's tight I
might want to join them wait oh my god
I'm a blood I can't do that
that's what I'm saying though because I
know who there are like I'm not I'm not
no hood hopping [ __ ] I'm an American
you know I'm saying
Jamal iam first but American but when I
see those videos though I got to give a
props because I see in North Korean
videos and I'm like you guys are
outdated this is some 1940s like [ __ ]
Cold War [ __ ] you need to up your game
because we got Isis over here that
modern-day technology and modern-day
cinematography their videos don't look
like it was made in 1960 you know what
the way selling this [ __ ] just gobbling
I could see that I know he's able to
tell what I saw Nazi uniforms I'm like
whoever was a fashion designer for the
Nazis they were well you know what
you're saying you appreciate the
craftsmanship you appreciate the thought
that goes behind it yes the message is
positive also says what a multiple
service I wish I had three Nazi uniforms
in my closet so I could try it on out
night I'm not gonna wear out of public
yeah it's dope their helmets are [ __ ]
cool right hey but they're wrong I hate
Nazis I hate I hate Isis right but I
hate up even more that they have cool
[ __ ] and they came up with it first and
our country didn't how come we didn't
have the [ __ ] point yes helmet that's
what wore one but still they had a spike
on their [ __ ] helmet dude just keep
in mind we have you guys are the most
influential people in this group so what
you say a lot of our viewers are leaving
in a Miss interpreter there to follow
well ultimately we have the dopest [ __ ]
because that's a given we don't need to
admit that like all the war movies
everything we do it the best right and
it's like I love watching the the
military blown up pirates but by the way
when the Pirates try to come and the
Somalian pirates they try to steal from
the cargo and then they [ __ ] get
blown up those you know like we got the
best technology right but let me tell
you this though I'm just trying to tell
all of our enemies right now [ __ ]
you're killing Isis North Korea all you
guys I just gotta let you guys know that
there's a few things you can do to do
better no we don't want them to do
better I'm just I'm just watching their
[ __ ] and I'm just a petition inspires
growth yeah well let them figure that
[ __ ] out because they make better videos
we'll make better videos and then don't
make better videos let me tell you what
videos are we making
we're in direct competition with Isis I
saw army like the army military Navy and
Marine Corps
shooting videos they up their game we up
our game they up their game we up our
game hello my mother ja Malians please
like the video and for more beautiful
videos look up there
[Music]
[Music]